all right um welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
unmute and ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in q a session at the end
second today's gdpr seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out finally the talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
youtube channel that's about it now let
me introduce our speaker today
it is an honor to host lexington who is
a professor of the mathematics at
stanford university where he is also a
member
of the institute for computational and
mathematical engineering
he specializes in scientific computing
and numerical analysis
in particular his research concerns the
design of numerical algorithms for
problems in scientific computing
in received his bachelor's degree in
computer science and applied mathematics
from shanghai
to tong university in 1998 he received
his ph.d from the current institute at
new york university in 2004
under the guidance of dennis jordan
before joining stanford in 2012 he was a
postdoc at caltech and a professor at ut
austin
the hours lexington has received include
a sloan fellowship in 2007
nsf courier hours in 2009 james wilkins
prize
in numerical analysis and scientific
computing in 2013
for his outstanding contributions in
many
many areas including the rapid evolution
evaluation of oscillatory integral
transforms high frequency wave
propagation and the computation of
electron structure
in metallic systems
and a silver
morning
side medal in 2016. today lexington will
give a talk about
give a talk
about pony's method
analytic continuation and quantum signal
processing please expect a wonderful
talk and enjoy it
now without further ado let me pass the
button to lexing by asking our usual
question that is what is your favorite
things to do other than research
sleeping
oh wonderful i like that that's one of
my favorite things to draw
yeah as well okay
all right okay uh
pruniness method so okay first thank you
very much for the invitation and it's
honored to uh describe to give this talk
here and i realized that the talk the
seminar series about machine learning
right so in fact
so but so this talk wouldn't not be too
much about machine learning but it's
it's more about traditional kind of like
apply math and and also content
computing okay it's not it's not only
about machine learning this oh it's not
only it's a data driven okay data driven
i see yeah okay yeah good and it is
data-driven man okay great so i'm uh so
here's the okay let me see how do i move
okay great so here's the content of the
talk
so the main player of this uh
of this uh
this talk is proni's method so i will
spend the first part of the talk
explaining what is punish method then
i'm going to talk about some of
my recent work on applying pronunes
method to do noisy analytic continuation
and also do quantum signal processing
okay
so first let's talk about what is a
pronunciation's method well the
primitive method is the way it's usually
presented is trying to solve a problem
like that so suppose you have a function
f x it's a linear combination of a few
fourier modes so here and d is the
number fourier modes
omega j is the frequency of the fourier
modes and r j is the weight of the
fourier moles okay
and you can observe
fks at uniform samples
uniformly sample the location so here we
just assume that fk is observed you're
given fk at the integer values of k okay
it doesn't need to be integers but
integer make things easier so then the
question is that how many frequencies do
you have in the signal can you discover
that and then can you figure out what is
wjs which is the frequencies and also
what is rj the weights okay
so classical solution which go back more
than 200 years is called brunis method
and this method itself is is well known
i believe in the control community and
then also in the ee community double e
community but somehow through the years
it's not it's got
i want to say loss but it's got buried
under
uh many other things i mean it's not as
well known as it should be in applied
mass community in a computational math
community so that's that's why i think
that it's
it's it's it but it's a beautiful method
and a lot of applications that's what i
want to share with you okay
so in the pruning methods um
okay the
let's take a look the data we have is f
k at integer values of k so let's denote
it by f sub k so this can be written as
a linear combination of these fourier
modes are valued at the location k
now let's go again recall that we want
to figure out where the d is what w j is
what r j is
now what we're going to do first is
we're going to consider these fourier
modes one by one okay so let's consider
three modes at the frequency wj and add
all the integer values and this will
give me this column vector here sorry i
yeah this is the first vector on the
left hand side it's an infinite long
vector
now what we're going to do is that we're
going to consider this upward shift
operator s so essentially shift
everything by one slot upward so it's an
infinite long vector so you shift it
it's doing infinite long vector so once
you shift it that the case entry would
be e to the i omega j of k plus one
now because the nice property of the
exponential function this is equal to e
to the i omega j k times e to the i
omega j so therefore
if you you you usually shuffle the
things a little bit you get this formula
s minus e to the i omega j times my
infinite long vector is equal to zero
now this is what happens with one
fourier mode so i have this s minus e
omega c operator but let's just take the
product over all the fourier modes and
consider this product operator applied
to the same infinite line vector
because there's only one operator s
involved everything commutes so
therefore this product applied to this
vector still zero
now let's do a linear combination on
this j now so each of the column itself
have two one fourier modes w j
but now
but but the j is arbitrary so therefore
i can just multiply each of them by r j
and then take a sum
so because the equation here equal to
zero equation here is linear so
therefore if you take a look at this
thing it's still zero
right
now but what do we have this in this new
infinite long vector
if you go back to the first line it's in
fact every entry is just fk so therefore
what this means is that if i take the
product of these shifted operators
applied to this fk vector is equal to
zero
now why is this useful the reason why it
is useful here now is that because now
you can see you have the product of
operator appear here so therefore i can
write this as a polynomial applied to
the operator s
and so this operator this polynomial
obviously take this form it's s minus e
to the i omega s take the product this
is equal to mz and this is equal to m0
probably
so recall that we don't know d here
because we don't know how many terms we
have in our
fourier our signal and we don't know
these coefficients and this is in fact
something we want to discover
now if you plug s back into this product
of operators and take a look at the
previous formula
this operator now becomes m applied to s
so you have m applied to s is equal to
apply this to this vector f k is equal
to zero
but what is
m applied to s it's just corresponding
to apply s multiple times to each of
this vector with respect to f right this
f is corresponding to this line vector
so therefore i get this formula
so i have different shifted copies of f
i multiply with certain constants m's is
equal to zero
and then you write this in the matrix
form so this is my vector f the first
vector is my back to f
okay
and then the second vector is my shifted
sf and the next vector so on so forth
the last vector is sdf
and these vectors do a linear
combination with weights m2 0 to md is
actually equal to 0. okay
now what does this tell us this tells us
that in fact i mean the rank of this
matrix has to be d
right because what i showed you here is
that by putting d plus 1 vectors you're
going to find the coefficient m0 to md
is equal to 0. but however because i
have exactly the
fourier modes any matrix with less than
d plus one columns will not will be full
rank so therefore by taking a look at
this matrix you will be able to figure
out what is the rank and the rank is
exactly d which correspond to how many
fourier modes in your original signal
and then by taking a look at null space
of this equation here you'll be able to
figure out what is m0 to md up to a
uniform scaling constant okay
the constant itself doesn't matter
because why because what we really care
about are the roots of this polynomial m
z so therefore if you find the roots of
this polynomial m z this will give you
the frequencies e to the i omega c
now here we're almost done because we
know what the d is we know what the e
omega j is right through root finding so
therefore all we need to do which is to
find the root find the least square
problem to figure out what are the
residuals so what are the weights rj
and will be done
so this is the whole idea of the pruning
methods what you want to do is that you
want to form this so-called hanko kind
of matrix and use the rank of the ankle
matrix to figure out d which how many
modes you have and use the null space to
figure out what are the coefficients of
the polynomial of with the roots equal
to these fourier modes
and then by finding roots you'll be able
to discover the modes and by solving
these square problems you'll be able to
find the ways
so the pruning method as i said is a
well-known tool in control and in
electric engineering but somehow it's
not so well-knowing apply math
it should be i mean in fact it started
from apply math but so um yeah but it's
a little bit unfortunate but i think
it's it's it's i mean it's it's a really
beautiful method
now it's adaptive it's very good because
it doesn't really care about where wjs
are right and it does not need to
require wjhs to stay on certain uniform
grid or or a pre-specified grid it would
the location of the wjj just pop out
from the route finding process so it's
adaptive
and it's also a direct algorithm because
uh
finding the rank and finding the null
space are pretty routine numerical
calculation now you can just open matlab
or python you will be able to do this
quickly
but on the other hand it also has some
shortcomings so for example it requires
root finding which is
sometimes that you uh a little bit ear
condition process okay uh so therefore
it's that's actually the main
disadvantage of the prunings method
because when the all these coefficients
f has noise ended the finding the roots
become a slightly unstable process okay
okay so this is the first part of the
talk i share with you what is bruni's
method and
i hope it's clear if not and feel free
to ask me questions
before i move on to the next step
okay
so now i'm going to talk about two
applications let's start with the first
one it's called the noisy energy
continuation
so analytical continuity in the
following problems
suppose you have a function gc which is
the relative function on the on on the
complex plane and the function might
have some posts might have some
singularities and
you know the function are set of points
and this set of points could be a curve
could be a line or could be just a set
of discrete points with a limiting point
and what you want to do is that you want
to find the value of this function
at other places on the complex plane
okay
so let's first consider simple problems
where this gz is represented by a bunch
of poles
at casij's it was residual rj okay so
this is my gz
now uh the main difficulty uh that we
face as as in practical problems
as engineers and scientists is that
often you only have noisy access to gz
you don't have precise values of gz and
gz come with some gaussian noise with
some other noise
and
in this example i'm specifically
interested in the case where the data
the gz is given you're allowed to sample
gz on this purple line which is the
imagine axis
so this case is particularly important
in many quantum chemistry and quantum
physics calculations in containers
metaphysics and uh and this is
corresponding to the analytic
continuation from the muscle viral
greens function to the so-called
green function
all right so the goal here but
mathematically this here's the question
i know i want i have access to the gz
value noisy access to the gz value on
the purple line what i want to do is
find how many number of posts do i have
what are the location of the post and
what are the residual of the post
now here um
i want to make one assumption which is
numerically it's necessary what i assume
that is that my pose which marked in
this picture as a red and also blue here
so
let me remark the post could be not
restricted real access so maybe this
picture is a little bit misleading but
the post could actually move everywhere
these red crosses and the blue crosses
could move other places on the complex
plane
so the assumption i want to make is that
all these posts are included in these
two circles where the first circle is is
centered at
b plus a over 2 with radius b minus a
over 2. so essentially this circle
intersects the real axis at two points a
and b
and the circle on the left-hand side
intersect the real axis at the points
minus b and minus a okay these are the
two circles which include all the posts
so why do i want to make this assumption
uh the reason that if i don't mix this
assumption then it's it's the problem
numerically and algorithmically it's
going to be hard because now you can
imagine this there's a pole which live
very very close to infinity right
somewhere close to infinity um
because of the decay of these uh the the
this is the pole function and near the
origin you probably don't feel anything
right so therefore unless you search
along the whole real axis imagine access
otherwise there's no way for you to
figure out where the pole locations are
so therefore that's why we need to make
some assumptions about our priority
information about the region of the post
okay so why this problem itself is
related to the pronus method well i mean
if you think about the pruning methods i
presented at the beginning of the talk
the data is giving spatial and a
temporal domain right you have the data
at the uniform grid x
and then index variable and the the
basis function or the things that you
want to recover is actually in the
fourier domain you want to recover the
frequencies
right and how many frequencies are there
but in analytic continuation the problem
is slightly different
is that the data is giving the spatial
domain by spatial i mean the complex
plane
and the the thing that you want to
recover the basis function is also in
the spatial domain because these are the
pole locations in the spatial domain so
therefore the problem ac and a
continuation and prone methods the
problem i mentioned earlier is is
different
but they're related as i'll show you
so before i dive into uh the the method
that i want to present is that i want to
say that this this work is actually the
problem analytic continuation has a long
history
it's related to the problem a rational
function approximation that relates to
the approximation
and then relate to the work for example
by back key and by approximation with
exponential sums
so all these are very important early
work some most of them are set in a
slightly different setting
but but the thing i'm going to present
is actually
borrow ideas from these methods
so i like to say that this is a huge
field a lot of references so what i have
here is clearly a non-complete as
incomplete list and uh and if anyone has
worked on that and
i didn't list your reference here i
apologize
okay so in order to apply the pronus
method uh so the first thing we're going
to do is something very simple conformal
mapping which you'll probably learn in
the first few weeks of a complex
analysis class
so record that our geometry the
following on the left-hand side we have
this circle z-plane which is a compact
variable because z plane where
the purple lines correspond to the place
where i can sample my uh g function and
and the the two circles are
corresponding to where i can place my
posts
so what i'm going to do is i do a mobius
transformation which is given here i'm
going to transfer into the t complex
variable so on the right hand side is
the t picture
so what does this transformation do the
transformation is going to
send this purple vertical imaginary axis
into a unit circle on the right hand
side
and it's going to send the right circle
on the left and left picture the
right into a small circle on the right
hand side and the left circle on the
left hand side to
the big circle on the right hand side so
essentially you can think about the
geometry has been warped the right
circle shrinked the purple line become
unit circle and the left circle got
unfolded and to become the bigger circle
now but the beauty of this complex
analysis is that if you have a polar
representative function which can be
represented the pole representation on
the left hand side after you do this
conformal transformation the warping it
still remains to be somewhat a bunch of
both modulus are constant
so this is what i'm saying here if you
take a look at the function gt it can
also be written as a bunch of posts at
different locations obviously because
you mapping a different space
and also with different weights
different residuals which are denoted by
wj here and plus a constant
the reason is that the pole is the
location where the function values goes
to infinity so i mean if you can
identify where the function goes to
infinity on the right-hand side you can
also identify where the function go to
infinity on the left-hand side
now
so
how do we figure out the pose uh in the
warped domain the t space
well the idea is to consider the
integral of this form i'm going to let
gamma to be the boundary of of
sign i have some mistake here i need to
correct but let's gamma is to be the
boundary of the unit circle so what i'm
going to do is i'm considering the
integral of this form it's 1 over 2 pi i
integral over gamma the boundary of gt
over t to the power k
dt over t
so the right the way around the y this
way is because you will see a second
because relate to fourier transform
what i claim is that the integral
of this for different values
of k will actually give me information
about the pose inside and outside the
unit disk
so first let's consider the k which less
than equal to one
so when k is less than or equal to one
um i can calculate this integral and
after doing a
few simple steps of the complex analysis
you see that this is actually equal to
the sum of all the posts inside the unit
circle this is sum over tau j is about
less than one
and multiplied by w j tau j to the power
minus k plus one so this is very simple
first year
complex analysis calculation so i will
not try try to repeat here
so what this tells you is that if i take
the different values negative values of
k and this will actually give me
information about different so-called
moments of the pose inside the domain
and similarly if i take the k to be
greater equal to one
take a look at the same formula this
will actually give me the sum of the
pose over the with a different sign for
the sum of the pose which is greater
equal to one which is negative moments
of the pose outside the region
okay so this is very nice
and
what makes things a little bit more
easier is that if you take a look at the
integral that i care about
in fact this is the integral over the
unit circle so when you're integrating a
function over the unit circle obviously
it's restricted it's very connected to
the fourier transform of the restriction
of the function to the unit circle
so in fact after doing like some
calculation it's clear that this
actually this quantity that i'm written
down at the beginning here is nothing
but the case fourier transform the case
fourier coefficients of the periodic
function g defined on the unit circle
okay
now we're ready to use the produce
method
how do we use that
well previously in the previous method i
considered a function which was vector
with infinite long vector in both ends
right because i have all the fourier
all the x's but here i'm only going to
consider semi-infinite vector
so let's consider k less than equal to
1. so we know that they contain
information about the posts inside the
disk so let's do that
so let's define the g minus hat vector
which is a negative part of the fourier
transform
when that negative part doesn't mean in
terms of the value but in terms of these
index right then from -1 all the way to
minus infinity
and this in fact is given by this
formula and and in fact this is given
through this calculation that on
previous slides because this is equal to
this and this is equal to that so
therefore this is in fact equal to the
minus the sum of all the posts of w j
tau g zero the letter g one so on so
forth
now you see that this is very similar to
the formula that the the the the the
formula that i had in the prunis method
and now i can play the same trick i can
introduce this shift operator s
and minus tau j and apply equal to this
tau j zero tau j one vector and this is
equal to zero because if i shift once
one slot and the vector is multiplied by
tau g
right
and i can take the product over all the
possible poles inside the region
for all tau i less than one i can form
the product of these shift operators and
apply to my just tau j vector and that's
give you zero because all these operator
commute
now
again here i have tau j but you see that
this operator becomes the same is
independent of j right when i take the
product it's independent of the j
previously it's depend on j but when i
take the product the independent object
so therefore now i can do the summation
of all the js if i do the summation of
the j multiplied by the wj i recover
this g
at the j vector okay here this step is
just last step is just doing linear
combination
and finally and this is equal to zero
now
you see that we have this product of
operator and by defining the product to
be a polynomial m0 t0 m1 t1 so on so
forth mdtd
okay and then
write this polynomial
replace t with s
plot back into this formula what we get
is that m0 times this vector g minus
plus m1 times the shifted copy of g
minus and md to sdg minus is equal to 0.
now i can write down exactly what is
shifted copy of g minus vector and and
write this as as a matrix equation
a linear system for the mds
so m coefficients and this will give me
this heinkel matrix which consists of
the negative coefficients of my fourier
transform
now we can repeat the last step of the
pronunce method but take a look at this
matrix figure out the rank i will get
how many what d is and these correspond
to how many poles you have inside the
unit disk
if i look at the null space of this m
vector null space of this matrix you'll
be able to figure out this m vector
which are the coefficients of the matrix
polynomial
and by finding the root of mz recall
that m is defined this way
by finding the root of mz you'll be able
to figure out tau j which are
corresponding to the post inside the
disk
so therefore by now i'll be able to
figure out what are the blue poles
inside the disk
okay now you can repeat the same process
for the sake of time i will not go into
the details
now but instead that you consider the
real part sorry the positive part of my
fourier coefficients and they will
actually in fact give me information
about the one over tau i where the tau i
are the poles outside the unit disk
so all we need to do now is again repeat
the same steps
find the m's
find the roots the roots will be 1 over
tau i by taking the reciprocal of this i
will be figuring out to be able to
figure out what are the tau i outside
the unit disk
so by doing this by look going through
the algorithm on these two slides i'll
be able to figure out exactly what are
the location of the blue poles and what
are the location of the red pose on the
right picture
okay in the t plane
now then the next step once i figure out
what are the location of these tile eyes
in the t plane what can i do is that i
can combine them together right inside
outside i group them together and i use
the mobius transform to bring them back
into the z space
so sorry for
going back to the z space once i go back
to this space i know where the poles are
in the z space and then at the last step
i can sort of use the least square to
figure out what the residual r js are
okay so that's the whole algorithm
so there's also a matrix version of this
algorithm where you can allow this g to
be a kept g to be a matrix and you allow
this r
to be a matrix as well so this is also
appear quite often in the so-called
quantum embedding calculations in
quantum chemistry and uh and this
actually in fact make the problem a bit
easier
so let me let me show you with some
numerical results
uh so for the complex pose so here what
i mean is that the pole location could
be anywhere in the complex plane as long
as you stay inside these two disks so
the two disks here are corresponding to
the disk which is really going from a a
is equal to one b is 200 so it's
corresponding to roughly about the disk
at plus 50
and also another disk at minus 50.
to be precise is 49.5
so
so here i give four pictures each of
them with different noise level so
because we are given noisy data first
picture no noise second picture 10 to
minus 6 10 to the minus 5 and 10 to
minus 4 so noise go up
every time multiplied by a factor of 10.
so you see that in the three pick first
two pictures and we almost recover
everything precisely so here the
red circles correspond to the exact
location of the post
and the blue star corresponding to the
recovered location of the pose by our
algorithm and the
green cross is corresponding to
worldwide sample on the dimensional axis
so uh so recall that that word we need
to sample in fact
i didn't mention this but you you see
that we need to compute these fourier
transforms so because in order to find
beautiful transform i need to know the
the function value on the unit circle i
can use trapezoidal rule to put the
points uniform on the unit circle and
when you do mobius transform to map them
back and these corresponding to this
extended grid like a stretching grid
gets sparse and sparser
kind of grid on the image axis
now you see that for the first three
picture we recover quite well but when
the noise is really high uh the problem
itself is ear pulls problems so when the
noise is large i mean you will fail so
this will show you that when the noise
is high uh in fact we will not be able
to recover the pole which is the
furthest of the way in fact the other
two posts nearby is actually going to be
pulled a little bit towards them so
therefore this is what happened to the
high noise regime and and i think any
methods would suffer something like that
okay
so
here's the case where we know a priority
the pose actually on the real axis so in
this case we'll actually in fact improve
the algorithms a little bit by
adding this prime information that
everything is on the real axis
so here i try higher noise previously is
from 10 to minus 6 to 10 to the minus 4
here 10 to minus 5 to 10 to minus 3 10
times bigger
so again you see that in the first three
pictures we have almost perfect
reconstruction but for the largest noise
and deteriorate
finally this is the case where the
matrix value case and as i promised you
i mean the it's it's more robust so in
fact we can jack up the noise so so so
so so the noise here is that going from
10 to minus 4 10 to minus 3 all the way
to 10 to -2
okay this is really large noise so you
see that in the first three picture no
noise all the way to 10-3 we have almost
perfect reconstruction of the pole
locations and the last one unfortunately
the because the noise too high and we're
gonna we missed up it
okay so uh this is the first uh example
so in fact we can actually uh consider
analytic continuation in a slightly
harder case
so this is the case that you if you open
a condensed method of many body
physics textbook and this is for example
the example the formula that you will
see now this tells you the so-called
greens function
over the whole complex plane using how
this is related to something called a
spectral function
so in the previous case we actually
consider this case where the spectral
functions coming from a bunch of deltas
that's the easy case and in fact we
allow ourselves to sample anywhere on
this multiplier line the imaginary axis
but however in real scenarios so you
only have noisy access of the greens
function not everywhere on the material
line but only on a very small but the
barrel grid
so here the material grid is defined to
be a uniform grid on the imagine axis
but this end here typically is only in
order of 100 or 200 so it's pretty small
and yet you want to figure out what is
the spectral function
so this is much harder to the the case i
just gave to you where you allow
yourself to sample anywhere on the
multiplier line
so we consider two cases one case is
called the molecule cases the second is
called the condensed metaphysics cases
so the molecule case is actually similar
to what i described earlier
but the main difficulty is that i only
have the blue segment which is short
segment where i i mean in fact i only
have a very small uniform grid i know
the master bar the green function data
and uh but previously i allow myself to
sample anywhere else
now in the condensed matter case the
solution is even more difficult because
your ax
your spectrum function could be anywhere
on the real axis so therefore that's
that's a much harder problem
let me not go into the detail but just
give you an idea about how do we solve
these problems again the tool we use is
conformal mapping plus prunis method
so in the first case uh the blue line
corresponding to where i have the much
better
data but the reddit correspondent to uh
were the support of the spectral uh
function
and the
the analytic function it actually does
is that it's
essentially does a rotation and does an
unzipping essentially it's gonna send
this blue segment into a unit circle by
tearing up the complex plane okay so you
can think about i'm using a scissor in
the middle picture and using scissor to
cut along the blue line and then unzip
it to become a circle
and once your unzip it become a circle
and you can again use the fourier
transform and to apply the previous
methods and the last line shows you
uh the results we have you see that the
noise level go from 10 to minus 6 4 3
all the way to 2.
in fact in the case of 10 to minus 4
and 10 minus 3
we're able to do almost like exact
recovery very nice so both in terms of
magnitude and also in terms of location
of the pole
and in terms of noise level 10 to minus
2 the noise is too high so we we wipe it
off in terms of the location and the
magnitude
so in the condensed matter case which is
even more difficult and the material the
blue line again tells you that where we
the the uniform of the paragraph grid
live
and with and and the red line
corresponding to
the red line corresponding to
sorry
the support of the spectral function
we're also going to do a conformal
mapping first we're going to do a mobius
transform to transform the red line to
circle in the blue line again to a
segment and then we use the same
function to unzip the blue segment use
this is a cut of the blue segment and
and zip it to a circle now you see that
because there's a conformal mapping the
red circle itself used in this nice red
circle in the middle is going to become
kind of like a penis shape because it's
a
an electrical transformation
all right so the last line tells you uh
what the results are so
in this case uh we have
five spikes so this the red
corresponding to the true spectral
density so we show a different noise
level 10 to minus 7 10 to minus 6 and 10
to minus 5. you see that in the first
first case we get almost perfect
reconstruction
and both in terms of location and also
the magnitude in the second case
the locations are all correct the
magnitude is correct for the three
middle ones and but the two ones at the
end points go down and this is because
that when you get further further away
from the master bar grid
i mean it the reconstruction
reconstruction becomes less and less
stable and in fact on the musclebar grid
you don't feel a lot of information for
the posts which far away sorry for the
spectral following
and finally when the noise level is
quite high and you see that it will only
be able to recover the middle one
correctly and because of the opposed
problem so uh there's nothing we can do
here because if the noise is too high
all right so this is the second part of
the talk and i i told you how to use
pruning methods to do analytic
continuation
and
any questions
all right so uh so the last part is
about uh uh quantum signal processing
okay so
uh quantum computing is a very hot topic
these days and in fact uh i would not be
able to i mean
go into the details but here we only
care about one uh interesting question
is something called quantum signal
processing so let me just explain where
the problem come up
so the first is that in quantum
computing all the operators that you're
trying to represent uh are present
represented
that you can represent it actually in
terms of these quantum circuits so when
the quantum circuits apply uniform
transformation on a hilbert space so
therefore all the operators are actually
unitary operators
however i mean you're building quantum
computer not just to do
similar to quantum mechanics right you
you wanted to do many other things for
example you want to do optimization you
want to do some linear systems you want
to do various other things
so therefore
often i mean this is also true even in
the quantum computing sense
quantum simulation sense is that you're
given a hermitian operator a where we
can scale it down so the norm is less
than one and it's n by n commission
operator
now in order to efficiently represent a
noun quantum circuit the question asks
yourself is it possible for me to
represent a using the only log number of
qubits
okay
now this is a hard question in general
the answer is no because if a is not a
unitary operator you cannot represent it
by exactly log number of qubits
but the beautiful idea is called a block
encoding it says that i cannot represent
a on
exactly this number of qubits but i
might be able to increase it one or two
or maybe three extra qubits such that i
can represent a somehow with this
slightly larger
this quantum circuit
in terms of the matrix
operator notation what essentially this
is doing is say that
i'm not trying to represent a itself but
i'm trying to represent a as the top
left corner of a bigger matrix where the
big matrix itself is unitary so in the
quantum circuit i'm going to represent
ua and if i restrict myself to a small
part of the circuit and output and i
will get a
so this is the beautiful idea of content
blocking coding
now this is a lot of literature about
how to actually give me an a how do i
um
get inform this blocking coding so this
is a lot of research on that and this is
another topic that i won't get into what
i want to get into is an extra step is
that suppose you give me the the
block encoding of a
can i get the blocking coding of a
function applied to a
why do i care about that
because this is really i mean most of
the scientific computing is about so
scientific computing in some sense is
all about to give me a matrix and i try
to
do something to this matrix represent
operator that's associated with this
matrix
so for example suppose you
let's take this function f x is equal to
e to the i
tau i tau x minus i dot x this is the
problem of quantum simulation because if
it is a hamiltonian this operator tells
me the schrodinger operator which meant
from initial time to the to final time
okay with the time period equal to top
the filtering is very important part of
signal processing but filtering is
really saying that i'm gonna on the
spectrum i'm just gonna care about
eigenvectors in a small window and so
this is called filtering
and also
this this operator's one of x is is
really just doing version because
a inverse inverting a operator that's
that's a solving linear system and uh
doing
single
signal processing is all about i mean
this is this is this inversion and
finally there's this operator which is
called fermi dirac operator this is like
a step function you care about the
spectrum below a certain point but you
want to throw away the rest
now the so the question is suppose i
have a block encoding of a how can i get
a blocking coding of fa
well this is answered by this paper
which is called quantum signal singular
value transformation so what is this
this work it's initiated from the paper
by low end child in 2017 and also
there's this billion-dollar paper
essentially
expanded and it explained a lot of stuff
so uh what essentially does proposed to
do is that i cannot do it for arbitrary
f directly but what i can do is that i
can split my f the function into an even
pattern order part of this minus one to
one interval
why do i care about minus one to one but
the reason is because
my operator a itself is bounded normally
it's bounded by one so therefore i all
the singular values is all the
eigenvalues come from minus one to one
but but once i have the even ordered
part what i'm going to do is i'll do a
function approximation i approximate the
even part with the even polynomial
degree d with
the where the degree is even
and approximately the odd part of my f
with a polynomial with order degree d
okay
now once i have these two
uh functions and then what i can do is i
can implement each of these polynomials
one even one odd with the right degree
using a quantum circuit like that where
this quantum circuit is mostly going to
use this ua which is the blocking coding
of a but at the same time it's going to
use some introduce some kind of like
very careful rotations denoted by
phi zero phi one all the way to phi d
where this c asks them for controlled
rotation okay
so now the job is that in order to
implement these polynomials uh apply to
a what we need to do is that we need to
find out what are these angles phi zero
all the way to phi d
now uh in quantum signal processing uh
so i mean so this is the quantum problem
but but if you but but if you i mean
trying to find out these angles in fact
it can be reduced to a very simple
harmonic analysis problem approximation
theory problem on the on the groups on
the matrixes of su-2 matrices
group of seo2 matrices so let me
reformat the problem a little bit give
me a polynomial ax which is of degree d
and it's uh the parity is equal to d mod
2 meaning that if it's an even
polynomial it's degrees degrees even
even polynomial if a odd polynomial of
the degrees are
and also that it's bounded by one on
this interval
what we want to do is i want to find
this face phi 0 all the way to 5 d
such that a x itself can be represented
by the top left corner the real part of
the top left corner of this big matrix
capital u here so let me explain for one
second so what is this capital matrix u
it's essentially given by this formula
at the end it's a product of a bunch of
two by two matrices where x and z are
partly matrices standard polymetry
seeing the physics notation
so when you multiply them together and
what you will get you get a two by two
matrix where
and p are actually a polynomial where p
and z are almost polynomials the
polynomials potentially multiply a term
look like square root of one over x
squared 1 minus x squared take the
square root so and what i want is that i
want this ax itself
is actually going to be
ax itself is the real part of the top
left corner of this matrix
okay so now
so the way to proceed i mean in the
literature the following is that give me
ax what i'm going to first is going to
do is to find out what is the p is what
r is
and once i find the polynomial p and r i
can roll back to figure out what are the
phase factors phi 0 to phi d
and in fact here i'm going to adopt the
notation that i'm going to denote by p x
matrix by a plus i c so a is the real
part c is a major part and also the rx
matrix i denoted by b plus id where b is
real part of i d is a measured part
now so the problem is just to well at
least yeah okay the problem is to figure
out what are the phase factor phi 0 to 5
d from this polynomial ax
now uh in fact to make things simple
what we can do is we can actually lift
it into uh from the minus one to one
unit interval in this interval to for to
a new space where t is from minus pi to
pi
so in fact this unit interval from -1 to
1 you unzip it becomes the circle and
this is the t is parametrized for minus
pi to pi
now so the the the the lift process
essentially is saying that if you give
me a function which is f x i'm going to
be able to define a function called f t
such that x is associated with cosine t
and uh and extended indirectly so folks
let me just give you an examples uh this
the formula itself is probably a little
bit tedious but hard to understand but
this is easy so that if f x is x then f
t function is just cosine t
if x x is square root of 1 minus x
squared and this f t just sine t
okay
now in terms of this um
in terms of the t
and this this problem that big matrix u
that we had in the previous i can reform
it this way is that give me a polynomial
80 i'll be want to find this pt which
the top left corner of is real part of
this pt whether this whole matrix is
represented by this okay
here now you don't have the cosine comes
up so everything is nice it's just just
t
now in fact sometimes it's also useful
to lift from the t space to the whole
complex plane so t is on the unit circle
right but i can lift and doing better on
a complex plane and these functions f t
themselves now becomes long polynomials
so let me just give you an example so
suppose the same example f t is equal to
cosine t here now it's going to lift
into this loran polynomial which is a
half of z plus over z
and if ft is assigned t then it's going
to lift to z minus 1 over z divided by 2
pi okay so so essentially you see that
all the polynomials that we try to work
on the x variable now becomes laurent
polynomial in the z variable in the
complex plane
now there are essentially two ways to uh
to to try to find these phase factors
uh one way is to so-called factorization
approach so this is approach which
proposed earlier so i have three
key papers and the one formulation we're
going to use it following this hot paper
from 2019
so you know
so in the heart paper what essentially
do is that given a what you want to do
is that you want to find a function b
such that a squared plus b squared less
than 1.
then you're going to form this 1 minus a
squared minus b squared
so on the unit circle it's actually
everywhere is positive
but if you take a look at the whole
complex plane this is the laurent series
and then another polynomial in fact it
has about the two d roots inside this
unit disk
okay this this function have two d so it
has two d roots inside unit disk
now what you do is that you define this
easy function if the cursor is a
polynomial of all these roots multiply z
to the power minus t just to balance the
degree and then you calculate this alpha
which is a constant factor
and then finally what you do is that you
do a linear combination of e z and e1
over z and that will give you a
polynomial c z and dz
and this is
c z and laurent zero c z and d z
now once you get a and b and you get c
and d you can recombine together p and q
and from p and q uh sorry from p and r
from p and r to calculate the face
factor is actually pretty
it's non-trivial algebra but but it's
fairly easy to implement it on computer
okay it's just like the word defined
standard routine
involves fully transforms
okay uh if you're interested i can say
more about this but but it's not really
directly related to how the prone method
is gonna come in
now this is a very nice
approach and the advantage of this is
direct
and but the disadvantage is that you you
require root finding right you need to
find these k c j's in order to form this
polynomial easy
and uh but the root finding in
high degree is in fact uh often not
stable because here the degree capital
at the lowercase d for the degree of a
polynomial can in fact go to like say
thousands or even tens of thousand
degrees so therefore root finding can be
not stable and in fact what you need is
that you need to use extended arithmetic
and the number of bits that you need to
use it grows like a d o log d of epsilon
so you need many many bits to calculate
these rules accurately
now because of this there's also a
second approach which are proposing the
literature
from this paper by doing it all so what
are you trying to do then forget about
all these polynomial q are uh v c d
i i just to put on the head of
optimization
uh
what you do is that you just directly go
find the angles phi such that
this the real part of the top left
corner of this u matrix right what i
have here
so which is p you take the real part
minus a you minimize it to make sure
it's as small as possible
uh the downside of this approach is that
it's highly non-convex
but in this paper what they showed that
if you optimize over
fixed type of faces meaning that
symmetric phases meaning that if you
take the vector of the physics you flip
it and you will get the same back okay
the symmetric phase and you start from a
good initial gas very special initial
gas empirically it leads to very good
solutions
and in fact it only uses a double
precision arithmetic so you don't need
to extend the arithmetic
now in practice this works quite well
but but you need to restrict yourself to
a certain type of phase factor and
certain initial guess
and
in a more recent paper what they show is
that in fact you can prove that this
optimization algorithm can made to
converge
under the condition that your function a
itself is not too large it's bounded by
1 over d
now
in practice it seems that you don't need
this but in theory this is necessary
convergence and and this is is not a
problem if d is small but if d is large
like a thousand of 10 000 this mean that
a has magnitude has to be very small and
this will affect the efficiency of the
quantum circuit
so now here i finally will be able to
explain what is the connection with the
prunis method here what we're going to
do is that we're going to propose a new
factorization algorithms so we're going
to follow this factorization approach
and to a certain extent then we're going
to follow this factor at the new
factorization algorithm
but without root finding so we will
circumvent the instability problem the
root finding
so so recall that in the per
factorization algorithm what you do need
to do is that you need to look at this
function 1 minus a squared minus b
squared you need to find the two d roots
inside the unit circle
and this step is a key step which and
then you form the polynomial easy right
the characteristic polynomial
and so this is the step where you have
instability comes in because you need to
find the roots
but the main observation is that i only
need a characteristic polynomial easy i
don't need the roots so the if somehow i
can go directly find the characteristics
for normal ez
right there's no need for me to find the
roots and maybe i can circumvent the
stability problem
in fact it is the case this is what i'm
going to show you
and so what we do is that instead of
looking at this polynomial the lorem
polynomial 1 minus a squared minus b
squared what we do is we look at
1 over this the reciprocal of this
so the beauty of this and the reciprocal
because it's a long polynomial so
therefore the reciprocal itself can be
represented by a sum of bunch of poles
now you recall that
what are the roots of
i mean the g is the reciprocal of 1
minus a square b squared so therefore
the roots of this 1 minus a squared b
squared what we need to find is in fact
corresponding to the the poles of g
right because it's a reciprocal
relationship
so therefore all we need to do is figure
out what are the poles of gz and in fact
we don't need them we only need the
characteristic polynomial of these posts
so this is where the pronunciation
method comes in
we take our old friend which is this
integral of gz now over the unit circle
by doing some calculation you see that
hey the fourier transform of gz for the
negative part of the negative fourier
coefficients is in fact associated with
equal to the sum over all the poles
inside the unit circle and it's the
negative moments of all these posts
in fact it's positive moments because k
itself is negative
so therefore again we're going to form
this vector negative part of the fourier
coefficients g minus 1 g minus 2 and so
on so forth and through the calculation
i have the previous slide this is in
fact equal to the linear combination of
the moments of the pose
now we repeat the same process i
introduce these shift vectors
and i introduce this characteristic
polynomial i know the characteristic
polynomial is corresponding to a null
space of this ankle matrix
now previously i mean when i talk about
analytical continuation i do need to
find the pose but here recall what i
need is what i only need the
characteristic polynomial
and then i multiply with z to the minus
d so if i only need this and so in fact
and this is where i can avoid the
stability problem i'm just going to stop
here i don't need the pose
to be the m i'll be able to find the
characters polynomial and i multiply by
z to the power minus d and i get easy so
i get e
okay
now this is not the end of the story
because
i still need to be able to i don't need
to find the pose but i still want to be
able to find the m's in a stable way so
in fact in order to find m stability
what we need to choose is that we need
to choose a
a certain
certain polynomial a certain function
which which we we choose to be sine
dt plus some small terms
now um in the literature in fact i mean
sometimes people choose b z equal to
zero and what here i showed you is that
and choose b z equal to zero is going to
be a bad idea to our algorithms
so here in the first row i showed the
picture what happened to bz and this
picture corresponding to this hanko
matrix here
okay in fact you see that numerically
the singular value drops dramatically so
which means that it has a huge null
space so which means that even though uh
theoretically there's only one
no spaces dimension one but numerically
it's actually very large so this will
make it very difficult to ping down what
is m vector
but on the other hand if you choose bt
to be equal to this sine times sine dt
and you see that introduced in the
second row of these pictures introduce a
huge antenna diagonal around around the
matrix along the enter diagonal of the
matrix so in fact the zero everywhere
away from the diagonal is close to zero
along this anti-diagonal it's a big
value so therefore this matrix itself is
very well conditioned and if you plot a
singular values you see that it has a
big singular values
everything is between uh 300 to 900
except the last one singular value is
equal to zero okay so this allows you to
ping down the uh
this b the null space b vector very
efficiently very accurately so let me
show you a few uh numerical examples so
the first example is called homotony
simulation where
this tau here corresponds on how long
you want to submit the hamiltonian and
this has a real part cosine tau x and
also a measured part sine tau x
now if if you these are the two
functions that the blue and the red are
the two functions that we're trying to
approximate using quantum signal
processing
so and the the lapse of the time period
go from one thousand all the way to five
thousand so tau is equal to one thousand
to five thousand and here you see how
the degree scale with these uh with with
with with the tile
and uh and this shows you the running
time how to scale with the tile and also
the error you'll see that running times
roughly about two minutes
three minutes and to find even the
largest tower value which is about 5 000
coefficients
phase factors and the area is roughly
bounded around 10 to minus 12.
and the second example is so-called
eigenstate uh filtering uh where
we're trying to ping down we only try to
project
what we're trying to
send the matrix a to its projection onto
the singular
eigen space which is close to the zero
so this ax is the function that we're
trying to approximate and uh
the the the delta corresponding to how
wide you want to the window near the uh
the zero eigen value to be the small
delta corresponding difficult case so we
go all the way to delta equal to zero
point zero zero five so one over data is
roughly about two hundreds
so you see that in that case the error
is also nicely bounded by
between ten to minus bounded by ten to
minus twelve
so this is the case of the matrix
inversion where the function we're
trying to approximate is the smoothed
version of the inverse function
obviously the inverse function goes to
infinity where you go to the origin
but in this case it's near the origin
we we smooth it out to make it into a
smooth uh as a wiggle and in this case
and the the kappa corresponding to uh
the condition number in the sense that
how
what is condition number of the matrix
that you want to perform inverse so this
kappa corresponding to the small
capacitor kappa equal to 50 means that
um
i want to invert the matrix with a
spectrum going from 0.02 to 1. okay so
when the
big kappa corresponding to the the
wiggle in the middle to be narrow so
it's more difficult
so the degree can go all the way to
about two thousand three thousand and it
takes about a little bit more than uh
uh about a minute well this is 200
seconds so it's no it's actually 20
seconds so this this case is very fast
and also the error is bounded by 10 to
minus 12.
now finally i have this thermodirac case
it's an order function it's a step
function it's going to project the
matrix into the spectrum part which is
less than zero
and uh you'll see that the error is also
bounded by 10 to -12
all right so this summarized my talk and
i talked about peruvian's method and
talked about the two applications
and these are the papers uh i post a
recent archive so if you have any
you're interested please take a look and
uh thank you very much for inviting me
thank you
thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk lexing um
thank you
yeah i don't know what happened to
network but thank you for everyone to
stay until the last minute
yeah yeah that's awesome and and uh we
have record recorded uh your talk so uh
the folks who
unfortunately love the talk only how
they can um
watch the youtube video again and
probably they can send the question to
you uh again well i do have a question
it sounds like you know the pronunce
method the that ass operator that you
you try to find
that's uh that's very similar to
you know command operator or the dmd
dynamic multi-composition formalism um i
i'm not sure you're familiar with those
methods
um
where you have a
the discrete vector um you know each
snapshot is um
it's it's snapshots you know you know
dynamically you know the stored and then
you try to find the linear operator a
which maps from previous time step
solutions to the next time step
solutions
and
they use you know they apply the the
compression technique svd
and then um
on the reduced space they
you know
do the eigenvalue uh the you know
decomposition to find out the the
dynamics in the in in the reduced space
so that that sort of formalism it seems
very similar to the pronunciation
maybe maybe there's a connection and
yeah maybe maybe it's similar yeah yeah
i mean
well i mean if pruning method is
developed i think it's
i don't know it's just 1791 or 1796
exactly like rooney so it's i mean it's
a long history and i think it's
i mean it's like propagating to
different communities and people use
different languages so it's very likely
that it's possible that i mean what you
described also a version of the prunis
method yeah exactly so i actually
quickly searched the internet and i
found this
the paper it's the title of the paper is
a a pruning uh approximation of command
mode decomposition so maybe
you will be interested in yeah sure yeah
i'll be happy to take a look
all right sounds good i will definitely
go back to the uh the recorded talk and
then um you know
you know go into more deep uh okay thank
you yeah
well thank you so much
thank you
oh oh okay let me
stop